Let's start with something simple.
Let's say I don't like having
to call an integer an Int.
Can we change that?
Of course.
We have the typealias statement, and
it always follows the same template.
It's typealias,
new name equal old names.
So, it would be typealias,
new name Integer, old name Int.
>From now on, I can use Integer
instead of Int whenever I feel like.
It's all the same to the compiler.
Let's see an example.
These two lines that we have
here are exactly the same.
Integer has become an alias for Int,
and we can use it any time we want.
This truly becomes useful when dealing
with funky types such as those of
functions and closures.
As an example of an odd type,
it would be a function or
a closer that takes an Int and
returns a name.
The type for
this function would be this, (Int)->Int.
That can be confusing.
I don't like it, so
let's give it another name.
And I'll call it InttoInt.
Now this is much better.
Now instead of having
to use this funky type,
I can use simply InttoInt,
that makes our life much easier.
Now let's create a typealias for
a function that takes no parameters,
void, and returns an Int.
And I'll call it IntMaker,
because it makes an Int out of thin air.
Now we can use any of these types to
define a function that takes an integer
and returns a integer, or one that
takes nothing, and returns an integer.
This will become very,
very useful in the next lesson where
we finally tackle variable capture.
See you there.